julian galles fouquières bonjour bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france donc au brésil
un traitement expérimental aurait été
testé un sur des des milliers de
personnes atteints du comique qu'est ce
qu'on en sait précisément aujourd'hui
on pas grand chose puisque ces
révélations sur ses récentes qui ont été
faits par la commission parlementaire en
charge de l'enquêté sur la gestion du
coc u19 ce que l'on sait c'est que dans
le but d'encourager les les
recommandations médicales que voté par
le sénat robert à l'époque qu'ils aient
plutôt des médicaments et non des
vaccins et notamment la question de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine effectué un
nombre de tests sur plusieurs patients
on sait que pour le moment ces tests
auraient pu causer la mort de 9
personnes que c'est une deux décès ont
été complètement caché qu'en plus c'est
ce traitement expérimental a été fait
sans aucun cadre juridique dans nos
légal the aucune autorité digne de ce
nom et sans aucune respect de la
déontologie et même de duchesse de
d'avoir prévenu les pères qui aurait
validé cette très près ce père d'aldo
c'est une honte c'est un gros scandale
qui touche actuellement la présidence de
dire bord soir au savoir aussi jusqu'à
où elle est impliquée dans cette affaire
mais de manière générale elle vient
révéler raisonner avec la gestion assez
calamiteuse qui a été de djè bi djè
rebours solal au delà de la de la
pandémie et cette histoire ne risque pas
de se terminer là alors que justement la
commission enquête continue son son
travail est en pleine avait 13 ans elle
se rappelle jusqu'à la prochaine vous
avez des élections présidentielles ouais
donc ce n'est pas anodin mais quel rôle
aurait pu jouer railleur bol sonar ou
dans cette affaire at-il de l'influent
sur cet hôpital ce groupe hospitalier un
peu plus précisément oui on brasse et
paulhan ça c est compliqué à déterminer
les liens qu'ont pu avoir et djebbour
cela vaut mais vous avez déjà plusieurs
membres du groupe et hospitaliers et
plusieurs témoignages qui disent que
justement ce ce test et c est ce ce
protocole a et d'effectuer avec son
approbation et dans le but effectivement
de confirmer les thèses qu'il mettait en
avant depuis le début sur
meadows on devait mettre en place pour
pouvoir lutter contre la pandémie
plusieurs d'ailleurs évoque sa totale
responsabilité avec le fait qu'ils
avaient la totale approbation du
président alors pour le moment c'est
quelque chose qui a saigné du côté de la
partie présidentielle donc tout ça ça va
être l'objet effectivement pour le
moment on se on serait bien de ça mais
tout ça va être effectivement les le
l'objet des révélations au futur et de
l'enquète mais de manière générale vous
avez un président du brésil qui a
encouragé justement cette logique thèse
c'est à dire de se méfier du vaccin
d'aller sur les traitements plutôt de
l'utilisation des médicaments de
descendre plutôt immunité collective il
a déjà une responsabilité politique
assez fort d'avoir permis un terrain qui
permet à prevent seniors de pouvoir de
pouvoir effectuer ce genre de ce genre
de test chef de protocole et après sa
responsabilité plus personnel plus
concrète va être d'autant plus établis
dans les jours et dans les semaines qui
viennent et quelle est l'ampleur du
scandale aujourd'hui au brésil
le scandale le scandale en lui même
vient bien raisonner avec une situation
qui est déjà camille calamiteuse comme
je disais on voit très bien dans votre
reportage vous avez déjà 600 morts du
brésil six cent mille morts dus qu'aux
vide oresys est le pays d'amérique
latine touché le deuxième pays le plus
endeuillé au monde plus de 20 millions
contaminées qui ont été établis et
notamment un vrai problème c'est que
très souvent malheureusement vous
observer que ces morts sont les
personnes les plus fragiles les
personnes qui sont le plus éloignés du
soin qui n'ont pas vu qu'ils n'ont pas
un accès de soins dignes de ce nom et
avec cette situation qui est déjà
calamiteux les cas où c'est justement le
sénat à ouvrir cette commission d'
enquête pour savoir qu'on est il de la
de la responsabilité politique du
président wade a appelé pour ça qu'ils
ont ouvert cette commission d' enquête
autour du coc vide et bien ce scandale
il ya bien raisonner avec une situation
qui est déjà extrêmement extrêmement
calamiteuse et vous le voyez d'ailleurs
pourrait faire un parallèle avec la
situation politique dans le brésil
rapport de force politique vous avez
donc les élections présidentielles qui
arrivent l'année prochaine et vous avez
bowles laroquais beaucoup perdu de sa
popularité et son concurrent qui est
lula da silva qui est pour le moment
favori dans les sondages donc
effectivement ce scandale arrive au pire
moment pour bosser la roue et vient
confirmer aussi sa gestion absolument
calamiteuse de duke au vide qui a été en
plus
parsemez de ses diverses provocations de
ses certitudes notamment payé par les
aiglons hydro secteur en chine de
l'immunité collective
se se méfiant totalement de la science
et des recommandations scientifiques
pouvait faire des organismes
internationaux ou même beaucoup de
médecins et d'organismes d'organisme
national et c'est pour ça que vous voyez
notamment des scandales comme celui ci
apparaît et qui résonne très fortement
actuellement brésil on a vu le président
rahim also narrow tenter d'assister à un
match de football refoulés parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas été vaccinés est-ce qu'il
as qui garde néanmoins un saut claude
d'électeurs un socle de soutien au
brésil le président humble sonar ou
oui oui ça reste le représentant d'une
droite dure avec certains secteurs de la
société
de la bourgeoisie des plus riches
notamment secteur secteur
est importante là bas qui est
extrêmement bien implanté et vous
observées dans les différents sondages
effectivement on allait il oscille entre
20 et 30 mai vous avez très et après se
pose aussi la dèche au second tour avec
moi il à la ilaha illallah de réserves
de voix mais il reste et il reste le
deuxième candidat le entre guillemets le
casque le mieux placé mais ce qui va
jouer c'est notamment le est ce que oui
ou non il va réussir à battre lula da
silva qui est candidat affiché de la
gauche unie de la gauche unie de
plusieurs organisations de gauche là
dessus pour le moment il est en retard
de 10 points donc il a beau avoir un
socle ce qui se joue en tant que
président c'est bien normal c'est sa
réélection et c'est là où ça va être
très compliqué et aujourd'hui les
brésiliens font un comparatif assez
clair vous aviez un président qui ont
plus a été bafouée et parce qu'il a été
mis d'ordre dans une enquête
préliminaire aller 1 1 car seul un quart
seulement préventif qui a été le cas de
lula da silva était complètement à
justifier en l'accusant de corruption
rien n'a été rien n'a été établie vous
fait le comparatif entre le bilan de
tout lula et les années du parti
travailliste quand les était au pouvoir
et vous fait le bilan avec paul larocque
en lui après est arrivé au pouvoir vous
observez que le parti travailliste c'est
plusieurs dizaines de millions de
personnes qui sortent de la pauvreté
aujourd'hui au brésil c'est la pauvreté
qui augmenté ces six cent mille morts et
c'est encore là j'ai vu une statistique
tout à l'heure 7 millions de personnes
qui vont peut-être basculé dans
l'extrême pauvreté voilà aujourd'hui
lalala le le la situation dans laquelle
se trouve le brésil politiquement
laquelle se trouve le brésil et sur
lequel va trancher et bien évidemment un
scandale comme celui là risquent pas
d'eux mêmes de manière générale toute la
gestion la gestion que molson araud a
fait du co lead va je dirais pas polluer
mais en tout cas va alimenter la
campagne présidentielle qui a déjà
commencé et qui va encore s'approfondir
la prochaine à lui avec les nôtres et
les brésil à avoir le choix entre deux
visions de
2,2 vision de la politique au brésil
entre lula lula da silva qui est un
bilan qui a été extrêmement positive est
saluée par beaucoup de monde et pour le
sun araw qui a un bilan est très centré
sur le peu vite parce qu'il était dans
les années 80 c'est comme ça qui est
extrêmement négatif et la voir faire et
le brésil vont avoir le choix entre ces
deux ces deux oppositions politiques de
positionnement politique merci beaucoup
je viens de camfoot fière d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin je le
rappelle vous êtes responsable du pôle
international des jeunes insoumis et
spécialiste de l'amérique du sud